[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar titled keynote panel
presentation successes and challenges
developing a 30-second photonic
detection diagnostic for the price of a
latte this webinar is part of the
clinical diagnostics and research event
and i'm susie valdez of labyrinths and i
will be joining you as your moderator
for today's event today's educational
web seminar is presented by labyrinths
so let's get started before we begin i
want to remind everyone that this event
is interactive and we encourage you to
first participate by communicating with
other attendees using the new live chat
feature joining in our presentation you
can find that live chat located at the
right of your screen you can also
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want during the
presentation to do so simply type them
into the ask a question box and click
send we'll answer as many questions as
we have time for at the end of the
presentation
if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing this presentation just simply
click on the help desk button located at
the bottom of your screen within the
navigation bar or from the lobbies
and finally as a reminder this
presentation is educational and offers
free continuing education credits click
on the continuing education credits link
located at the abstract window below the
presentation window and follow the
process to obtain those credits without
further ado i now want to introduce our
two speakers
first joining us on audio today is osmo
mirza the chief executive officer and
co-founder of sardarian technologies
mscgh global health at
duke university and duke global health
institute and joining her on video is
tra tran the director of development and
clinical affairs at stereotypian
technology for complete biography of our
speakers please visit the biography tab
at the left of your screen
welcome ladies you may now begin your
presentation
thank you so much and thank you for
having us we're
really excited to talk about
you know the
essentially the process of testing where
we go from bench research to
a fully developed um
device so
we have been developing a 30 second
photonic detection diagnostic and our
goal was to get it down to the price of
a latte
so today
just for an overview we're going to go
through the problem in our solution
we'll dig into the science and then
something that's really interesting is
when we do look at something
that takes into account a lot of the
hard sciences in order to translate it
into diagnostic technology you have to
have equity and human centric design in
mind so we'll discuss a little bit of
that
and as you can see from here we hope
that you're able to understand the trial
and error process
in developing a new device the breakdown
of designing and testing an equitable
technology and then navigating the
advantages and disadvantages of
poc diagnostics
all right so
what is the problem and how did we begin
this
essentially we looked at the diagnostic
market and we saw that it was really
large it was really resistant to change
and there were certain things that just
were kind of keeping a backlog and it
was really noticed during covid so
things would take a lot of time you had
one test for each disease so there
wasn't one platform where you can kind
of come on and be able to see different
diseases and then there were a lot of
steps you had
labs you had people you had somebody
running back and forth taking blood
samples so it wasn't as easy as we would
envision medicine to be in 2021.
so what we did was we developed a device
that can do breath fingerprinting and it
uses photonics so it takes about 30
seconds from the time you insert a
disposable cartridge and you can see
that on the right hand side we have a
cartridge for stars kobe 2. we're
developing one for h1n1 and one for lung
cancer and the device on the left hand
side is the photonic device and really
the differentiating portion
is that it's multi-use
there's no assay in here so there's no
wash step it takes one step to do all of
it you get your results immediately
not only do you get them immediately but
you can kind of tell numerically what
the viral load concentration may be and
then it's low cost easy to use and it's
completely portable
but we were not always at this point and
i'll tell you kind of how we got there
so what we were doing as a company was
we were creating human super sites and
how did we end up in photonics and
diagnostics is the question here um what
our device would do
is it would take any external thing that
a person was looking at if they wore
these glasses and it would project it
back onto their retina onto the back of
their retina to be very specific and we
were planning on using it in surgery and
aerospace exploration
and then the pandemic hit and we saw
that there were so many different points
of pain when it came to
rapid testing and so what we did
was what we previously looked at
on the left hand side you'll see it says
oh lead display that was the display
that would take any external source and
then project it onto the back of the
human retina so it was photonics that
was using
very discrete focal points to be able to
kind of hack into human augmentation and
we took that
and we used the same exact device to
create rapid diagnostics but now the
issue was where we had an oled display
before we now had to introduce a
biological component that would be able
to react fluoresce and then be able to
hit a detection system or a
photomultiplier tube that would be able
to amplify it so really
our bread and butter was engineering but
now we were like how do we get back to
the bench to the lab and actually start
implementing
verifying and validating the biological
components that we'll need to test
so that brings us to the science
and this was quite a long road so if you
think of
a basic testing life cycle at the very
very basis of it you start off with
validation you go to verification
you might go back to validation again
come back to verification
swing in that area for a little bit then
you go to feasibility and design
from there you're just reiterating over
and over and over again and then
eventually you go to development and
this cycle is
is non-stop there's no end point really
um and in the pandemic the cycle i will
tell you was not this streamlined or
this linear
it was we would go from validation to
feasibility and design to verification
to thinking we're at development
realizing we have to go back to
reiteration
and so what we ended up with was
a very very um
uh simple schematic for the purposes of
this presentation we decided we would
insert as you can see on the left hand
side a disposable biosensor cartridge
the goal was to have a molecular beacon
or an optimal that would flow rest once
it reacted with
a specific spike on coping 19.
once it reacted we would irradiate it
and it would fluoresce and all of the
photons would bounce off into our
proprietary mirror which would cause
them to come back and collect at the
controller
and this would all happen at the speed
of light which was great and then you'd
have a quantitative output so from the
engineering side we were golden we were
we were pretty confident on how to move
forward but on the biological side
what we realized was we wanted a
requirement where we didn't have a wash
step we didn't want to add any
additional steps we needed to be able to
distinguish from bound tags to unbound
tags so if you're thinking of a
molecular beacon which i'll show you in
a minute um it generally has a quencher
and
once it binds to a very specific target
only then does it fluoresce so we needed
to be able to have that differentiation
in
wavelengths and then we wanted to use
fluorescent activation wavelength shifts
and photon emissions to really hit this
home
and on the right hand side you'll see
what we were trying to avoid which is
the multi-steps of analyzer tests um the
multi-steps of also pcr tests which
really are the gold standard but when it
comes to public health they do take a
long time so what we wanted to do for
the roomie was collect the sample
irradiate and read the results
and so the plan
was to have something pre-reaction
an optomer bound to an antisense or
a molecular beacon that had a
fluorophore and a quencher and upon
seeing the target protein
they would break apart the optimal would
have higher affinity to the to the
protein and then the 404 would be
excited
and luckily enough we were able to
accomplish what you see on the left hand
side
where we compared our
probe to cobit 19 and sars and as you
can see
the binding to coven 19 was beautiful
so that's what we had on the biological
side
and on the
hardware side what we wanted to do was
make sure that truly indeed we could
focus what we found in breast condensate
and be able to
have that discrete focal point and get a
good limit of detection so we were able
to get about 500 infectious units in a
sample and for cobin 19
you generally have about 10 to the 9th
in in alveolar air because we're using
breast samples
but this is not an easy road
here you can see
we were testing it again several
different variants there was a high
level of cross reactivity
we're still kind of working through a
little bit of this
when you think of cross reactivity in
other areas of the world
it might be a problem because mars is
still around but in the united states we
don't really see it as much so we're
pretty confident that our optomer when
it does bind it would be to cover 19.
and and that's kind of where we were in
the beginning we were just testing we
would see a lot of asthma we had started
off actually with a molecular beacon and
the molecular beacon was not binding
properly there were
a lot of kinks
in the hairpin loop and then we decided
to switch over to doing a sense and
antisense probe and that ended up
working
much better for us
and here are just some of the results
that we had from the first time around
as you can see
with optimal complex one is the optimer
that's bound and optimal complex two is
another optimer that's bound then we put
it in with covid and what we saw was a
very very slight reaction shift so
we found an increase in fluorescence in
the presence of the protein and
increased quenching in the presence of
the protein which is not good
and we thought maybe it had to do with
some contaminants the first time around
we did it in water then we switched over
to buffer
there was a lot of trial and error while
at the same time we're still developing
the hardware
and again you can kind of see here you
know the quenching was pretty high and
that's not what you want when you're
trying to get an optimur to bind
pretty specifically to a target of
choice
so now moving on to the hardware
one of the
trickiest parts was condensing the
aerosol particles so when you have
somebody breathe in
what we needed to be able to do was take
their breath and condense it
into a condensate that would then react
with the optimers in
at the bottom of the tube so we have to
use a tc controller and a thermoelectric
cooler to be able to
really take the breath cool it down and
create a vapor out of it that was one of
the coolest things that we've done um on
the on the breath side of things we have
to do a lot of nebulization work in the
lab but now we're able to collect breath
um
using our device and and we're actually
about to partner uh with another
initiative that is going to be using our
breast collection for
testing another
respiratory disease so there's a lot of
different aspects just using the device
itself
but for us we really wanted to move
forward with covid19 be prepared for
this pandemic and be prepared for the
next pandemic
so that's on the air side then we had a
lot of issues with filtering the light
we had to set up collimating lenses we
had to have filters we had to have them
at several different angles and and make
sure that the way that the light was
bouncing off
to get to the photomultiplier tube was
in in such a way that we were not losing
any of the photons that we collected
and that took i would say about
two to three months of just trial and
error back and forth with our electrical
engineers with um
you know the mechanics portion of it so
a lot of it was just
printing 3d printing and reprinting and
just seeing what fit and what didn't
it was a lot of hours in the lab
and then something that we actually got
from our eyesight recreation
um
device was edge detection so in the
eyesight recreation device we wanted to
be able to have somebody really be able
to see where the edges were so we took
that from our software and now we're
able to use edge detection to make sure
that we reach that threshold of the
sample that will be standardized across
every single person that flows into the
tube so it's about 15 microliters and
you can see
up on the right hand corner
um an actual photo of what that looks
like so once you blow into it the
thermoelectric cooler starts the roomy
device will actually
start flashing when you've hit that
field detection so
a lot of really cool innovative things
that we were able to do along the way
because we had to go back to that
reiteration process and then go back
from reiteration to validation to
verification so it's been pretty fun
and now we're at the point where
really we're looking at the reiteration
and um i'm really excited that trial is
going to talk to you a bit more about
this because for us the reiteration has
to do with
the human-centric design so the
biological components the workflow
and the actual optics of the device work
but will they work when it's out in the
field and what you see in front of you
is essentially the model that we think
we will use for production
it'll have micro displays it'll have a
custom controller board that will
replace a lot of the things that we have
in the lab
we need custom battery packs because
it's very important for us that this
will be portable and then we want it we
want to have a trigger to start the test
and that'll irradiate the substance
it'll start thermoelectric cooler etc
and so the roomy workflow is really
supposed to be four steps where you
select the cartridge of choice
you insert it into the device the
patient blows into it
it'll indicate when they have an express
sample
once it has enough breath sample it'll
start the test and it'll display a
positive or negative in 30 seconds but
it'll also give you a quantitative
concentration of the pathogen load and
then it can seamlessly send this
information to any network of choice so
we have a software system that can help
you connect whether you're out in the
field or if you're at work or at school
it will be able to help you connect to
those networks with completely
de-identified data
so right now we are
finishing up with breath and water we've
validated the use of big rumi and those
two samples but we really want to move
forward to saliva sputum urine and blood
and as you can imagine they come with
their own host of
trials and tribulations when you're in
the lab
specifically
we may need to add one step and and that
doesn't really go according to what
we've wanted which is to keep the single
step but sometimes when you're
innovating um you do need to take into
account that the first iteration may not
be exactly what you want at the end or
what you'll be using in the field so
especially for something like saliva and
blood
we'll have to isolate different portions
of the sample to be able to see how we
can really make the most use of it
so overall we really believe in
photonics and for healthcare solutions
because it helps with the amplification
which causes you to work at the speed of
light you can make things single step
there's a lot of versatility in
applications so
you
because you're doing the amplification
and detection via photonics you can use
this in a host of things whether it's
checking water for environmental safety
to checking at checking chemical and
biological warfare in
air
to looking at diseases in breath whether
they're communicable diseases or
non-communicable diseases it allows you
to have portability you don't need a lab
to prep anything and it's very
inexpensive because you don't have
reagents you don't have buffers
and at least you don't use as much as
you would in in a general asset
but again
the disadvantages are that you have a
hundred thousand iterations
novel technology requires adoption so
before you go in and you have this
amazing idea you do need to be able to
look at once i'm out of the lab what
does the commercialization of this look
like how will people be convinced of the
fact that we're doing this amazing
science but it'll translate to real life
benefits for them as well
and then there are a lot of regulatory
hurdles
if you think the testing life cycle i
showed you earlier was complicated the
regulatory life cycle is a hundred times
more complicated because
um with anything that's new
you have to have the burden of um
as proof to be able to show that we are
not using lasers that will blow through
somebody's mouth
and so a lot of a lot of common sense
things you really have to kind of um
lay it down write it out and be able to
defend the technology
and be able to have your data ready
thank you so much asthma and
i think that a lot of the science that
you guys have been able to do and that
we've been able to do so far is really
interesting um i'm going to talk about
what it means to design for
human use and also with equity
in mind
so
first i do want to acknowledge like asma
did that
this process is not linear and that a
lot of times you're going to have to go
back to
stages that you thought you've already
accomplished because you're going to run
into a problem that you just really
didn't anticipate
um
but in general these are kind of these
six high
level
steps that you need to take to take an
idea or innovation and get it at least
in front of a person
so first you have to have an idea for us
that was developing
the rumi after we pivoted
from
the eyesight technology
then you have to experiment and
establish a proof of concept in the lab
that was a lot of the science that osmo
just went over
and it's really really important for you
to be able to develop
a working prototype that you feel
comfortable
using with people because then your next
step is establishing a proof of concept
in the clinic this is where you're going
to start
doing
research with human subjects and is also
where
you now are entering an entirely
different realm of regulatory procedures
and rules
after you have
a working prototype that you feel very
comfortable
giving to somebody else
so you don't need your team of engineers
or researchers or designers at hand
then you can start really engaging with
the fda to develop a regulatory pathway
and
you can begin conducting your clinical
trials
i think that a lot of these steps are
really important
but stage four is crucial for you
to
think through before you start because
you don't want to waste your time or
your money
um
conducting a clinical trial that maybe
you don't need or developing data that
may or may not be sufficient enough for
the regulatory body you're submitting to
after you finish all of that awesome
work you then have to develop and
implement a quality management system
for your technology at this point you
need to have design freeze and you need
to have already i like figured out who
your
subcontractors are manufacturers are etc
at this stage you will also
begin
achieving your fda approval once you do
get that and you have your quality
management systems in place
and you have your manufacturing in place
you can then start doing
the other nitty gritty work of getting
your technology into people's
hands
granted every single market requires
a different regulatory approval process
and market strategies so
you definitely want to have to
definitely start with one and then move
forward
however it's always crucial to innovate
with purpose and it should be driven by
real world problems that need solutions
for us when we were developing the rumi
we saw
proven 19
and
rapid point of care diagnostics as a
huge and critical need for not just us
as individuals but for like the global
world and society
we really believed that our technology
could really fill an important need but
we weren't 100 sure which is why we
really wanted to talk to end users
um so people who would be administering
the roomie or people who would be using
the rumi on a daily basis to better
understand
whether or not our technology can
actually
accomplish our goal which is solve a
problem
so a great way for you to incorporate
end users early in the design process is
through conducting these interviews and
this is kind of a process
that should be iterated iterative and
done throughout your entire design
process
this is a way for you to really begin
doing human-centric design because
you're incorporating the people who are
going to use it at the end of the day
very very early on
we really believe that understanding how
our technology will be used
is
how we can better design
in the future not just for our covid19
prototype and copen19 application but
for
lung cancer and other diseases in the
future
however we have a lot of challenges like
everybody else does when it comes to
bringing novel technology to the people
who need it most
for us we've run a town run into
challenges around finding funding
around
developing and getting data around the
regulatory pathway and executing
clinical trials
our first hurdle is a catch-22 that i
think a lot of you might be familiar
with which is you really need data to
get funding but you really need funding
to get data
there's a lot of ways that you can work
through this problem such as
getting grants collaborating with other
institutions that might have more money
or finding investors
and while all of these options do have
benefits they all have different kinds
of consequences
so it really depends on not just your
innovation but your level of support
if you're able to get past this catch-22
you're then going to be faced with these
critical decisions like developing a
regulatory pathway
for us we're really trying to decide and
understand whether or not
a de novo
process with the fda is better than a
510k or
whether or not it's better for us to
incrementally
apply with the fda or do it all in one
go
each of these different
pathways will
change not just
our development but also our market
strategy so
i highly suggest that you try and talk
to as many experts as you can in
regulatory science before you really
start
pushing this stuff through
another thing that you really have to
think about before you engage in
clinical trials
is your ultimate use case of your
innovation
so when we're talking about point of
care diagnostics
we're talking about
who is going
to administer it
who is going
to um do the data collection who will
need to process it
will this be used for diagnostics or
will this be used for screening
are you going to use it at home
are you going to use it with children
all of these different use cases require
specific safety and efficacy data
for again
different regulatory bodies to review
so
while some technologies might not
require a lot such as like a new tongue
suppressor or something like that
i would say
the more invasive your technology or the
larger the claim you have the more data
you will need to be able to prove to
people like the fda
that
your technology is safe and providing an
accurate diagnosis or screening
another thing we really want to think
about is designing with equity in mind
and
for me i really like to use the world
health organizations
definition for them equity is the
absence of unfair avoidable or remedial
differences among groups of people
whether those groups are defined
socially economically demographically or
geographically
or by other dimensions of inequality
health is a fundamental human right
and health equity is achieved when
everyone can attain their full potential
for health and well-being
i think that this definition is great
because it's really expansive in terms
of what we think about when we're
thinking about differences but it also
is very cognizant of the fact that
we
are different in general as people
um when we think about health equity in
designing new medical devices
for us we really tried to think about
diagnostics in terms of stuff that's too
expensive
um getting a diagnostic that might take
too long or it's too far away for you to
get to
it might take too many steps so there
are too many follow-ups for you to deal
with
and also trying to combat stigma of
diagnosis
how he did that was through a variety of
things and
they really kind of point to these three
critical
aspects of health equity we want to try
and increase access both physically by
making sure our device
is battery operated and portable but we
also want to make it accessible
economically so we're trying to make
sure our tests are less than three
dollars
we want to increase access by
eliminating the need for follow-ups so
we want to make it one step and because
we are able to have the room connected
to telehealth
it will
hopefully allow
for
easier and faster diagnosis in
places that may or may not
have
health clinics
again we also want to design
with stigma reduction in mind because we
recognize that
being screened positive for something
even like covet 19 comes with
social
things
a part of the beauty of the roomie is
that it is small and discreet and that a
lot of the screenings or diagnostics can
be folded into regular health checkups
we also believe that the oral
administration of the rumi will help
decrease stigma by not leaving any signs
of testing left over
we also believe that
we want to increase equity in point of
point of care diagnostics because
accuracy is critical for the continuum
of care and the development of future
health plans
and we believe we can do that
by eliminating a lab and reducing human
error and providing a qualitative and
quantitative results
almost immediately allowing providers to
understand
not only if their patient is positive or
negative but also hopefully where they
are in
their disease spectrum
granted there are always unintended
consequences when you're developing new
technologies and when it comes to point
of care diagnostics it's really critical
for all of us to think about
what is our role in the continuum of
care like what what happens after
your device tells someone they are
screened positive
is it
do you need to provide information on
treatment do you need to ensure that
these results get to a particular
body such as the public health
department
a lot of these questions are not
necessarily things that we will think
about very early on in the design
process because
it takes so much
just to get your technology to people
however
things like unintended hipaa privacy
violations will come into play when
you're trying to get fda approval so
it's always good to think about it
early on another really important aspect
of innovation is ensuring that the
technology we develop does not increase
inequities that currently exist
and one of the things that
i think we've really seen recently is
this reliance on telehealth
especially because of coca-19
however
telehealth requires people to not only
have an individual device but for that
device to be able to conduct a hipaa
compliance appointment which requires
strong and consistent internet you also
need a room or space where you can talk
to your provider
alone which
is not really possible for a large
proportion of this country let alone the
world so when we're developing
technologies it's always important to
remember
that not everything can solve social
problems so we need to be cognizant of
those social problems as we move forward
so thank you guys so much for listening
to us i just want to go over a little
bit of where we at steradian
technologies are now
we are the grand prize winners of
x prizes 6 million rapid coca-19 tested
testing open innovation track
competition
this has allowed us to begin our initial
feasibility study
where we are doing device integration
which means we are integrating the roomy
handheld device
and the
disposable biological cartridge
we're also conducting a feasibility
study which is our first study
with human subjects using the root me
and we are developing a regulatory
pathway with
different consultants and regulatory
scientists
we are also
because we are able to work as a
platform detection device
working on
detecting early stage lung cancer with
johnson and johnson
and developing a multiplex with
kova 19 and h1n1 and hopefully in the
future
the entire flu spectrum
with la jolla institute for immunology
and x prize and we also are having very
interesting and exciting conversations
about using the roomies
breath concentration technology in tv
so we're super super excited about all
this stuff that's to come
we hope that you guys enjoyed our
presentation and we're able to learn
about these different things in terms of
what it takes to go from ideation to
innovation
how you can design with people and
equity in mind
and what are the advantages of point of
care diagnostics
lastly we want to say thank you to
everyone
on our team everyone at lab roots
everyone at xprize and of course our
incredible scientists and innovators
thanks
and thank you both for that informative
presentation
we'd like to now start the live q a
portion of the webinar and if you have
any questions you want to ask please do
so now just click on ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
so let's get started it looks like we
already have some great questions coming
in
our first question how would
multiplexing work
sure i can take that question this is
asthma
um so the way that multiplexing would
work is on the device side we would need
to have
different filters that could filter out
different wavelengths and then
be able to bring them to the
photomultiplier tube
and be able to differentiate which
wavelengths are coming in because we
would still want to know
the relative concentration of each one
of those biomarkers or pathogens that
we're looking at and then on the
biological side what we would need to do
is have different molecular beacons with
different fluorophores attached to them
to be able to differentiate and then it
would be very important to make sure
that there isn't any cross reactivity in
the biosensor itself so it would
definitely be a multi-step process
but it can it can be done which is very
exciting
thank you so much and how would you
expand into other samples
um so
when we think of other samples on the
device side not much would change
what would likely change is on the
cartridge side
so if we are looking at blood
when you take blood when you take a
blood sample
you may have to isolate it into its
different portions and then pipe that
out
the layer that you're looking at
insert that into the roomy device and
then look at it so that's just a very
high level way of of thinking about it
but
you know as innovators and as scientists
we definitely believe that there's
something there that we haven't hacked
yet um but i think expanding into other
samples just strictly from a
testing life cycle stage
we would have to do a lot of lab testing
um without even using blood in the in
the beginning we would just have to
figure out different ways that we can
isolate things so
it would be it was again a multi-step
process all of these would be multi-step
processes
thank you so much esma and i want to
thank our audience for these great
questions
where do you see your device being
adopted in screening or diagnostics
yeah
okay so it really depends on
what disease we will be looking at i
think for
things like lung cancer we're really
looking at screening
in terms of
covenanting at home use it would also be
screening but covid19 in the clinic
would be a diagnosis
so
use case also really matters here in
terms of where it would be adopted but
we do believe that
because it's
a platform device it would be able to
sit well in any
primary healthcare
position
wonderful thank you so much and we have
a couple more questions coming in
was your pivot intentional and how early
in the development was your original
device
um that's a great question so the pivot
was not intentional um
we were
very very excited to kind of be in the
space of deep tech and
the recreation of human eyesight to just
human supersite
would help for anything from retinal
degeneration to better accuracy and
surgery
and so we had started our pre-clinical
testing and studies for that but when
the pandemic hit we have to pull back
all of that because nobody was allowed
to go into the hospitals around
you know march 2020
everything had to seize and halt um and
we were just very serendipitously
talking in a meeting and
we were discussing the lack of public
health initiative when it came to rapid
diagnostics and
we kept thinking why aren't they fast
enough and as we dug through that
question
it dawned upon us that
hold up what if we use our device
to
maybe use photonics for diagnostic
testing and that's that's how it came up
so
we we didn't even have a device we just
had the internal mechanisms of eyesight
recreation and we started from
you know
a blank slate
so i would say we weren't even early in
development this was
nascent
thank you so much
we have one more question coming in is
there a difference between communicable
and non-communicable disease
diseases
yeah i can answer that one there is a
difference for us in terms of how and
what we are going to identify using the
rumi
for communicable and non-communicable
diseases
i think
the
biggest differentiator is that with
communicable diseases we're
more than likely able to look for
the disease itself whereas with
non-communicable diseases we're looking
for
the way that the disease will affect the
body if that makes sense
absolutely
ladies i want to thank you for your
presentation today would you like to
provide any closing remarks before we go
yes um we are so grateful to be here and
um to engage with a community that
innovates and tries to make the world a
better place through science and we're
always looking for
scientists who are interested in
technology such as ours we love
collaborating um so please feel free to
reach out to us
and try
do you want to add anything
no i think usma totally got it all to
everyone
perfect well thank you again asantra for
your time today and for your important
research and before we go i want to
thank our audience for joining us today
and for their interesting questions and
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted on the on-demand
period will be addressed via the speaker
using your contact information you
provided the time of registration and
this webcast can be viewed on demand for
two years until november 2023 labrets
will alert you via email when it's
available for replay we encourage you to
share that email with your colleagues
who may have missed the live event until
next time take care everyone and stay
safe bye